ça vous dirait une petite bière à
consommer avec modération chaque année
les Français on consomme 30 L en moyenne
par personne 51 % d'entre eux la préfère
même au 20 et si aujourd'hui on
fabriquait notre propre bière exczmoi je
connais un endroit où on ne brasse pas
que de l'air mais de la bière mais
auparavant un petit tour par
l'atelier
[Musique]
depuis quelques années la France connaît
un véritable boom de la bière artisanale
avec 2500 brasseries c'est même le pays
d'Europe qui en compte le plus mais
avant de nous lancer dans le brassage
c'est le terme consacré un petit retour
en arrière qui a inventé la bière de
l'eau de l'orge
duoublon de la levure voilà les quatre
ingrédients à partir desquels on
fabrique la bière depuis la nuit des
temps car sa consommation ne date pas
d'hier il y a quelques années des
archéologues ont découvert dans une
grotte en Israël trois récipients
contenant des traces de bière vieilles
de 13000 ans les Égyptiens aussi en
fabriquaient et il lui accordaient une
grande valeur les ouvriers qui
construisaient les pyramides recevaient
5 les de bière par jour faut-il en
déduire que sans la bière les pyramides
de guisa n'existerait pas au Moyen-Âge
c'est une boisson très appréciée en
Europe ce sont les moines qui la
brassent ils sont passés maître dans
l'art du brassage depuis que charlesemne
leur en a confié le monopole d'où
l'appellation pierre d'abille pas
étonnant que certains la boivent
religieusement à noter que les moines
bénédiictins de saint-vanderille en
Normandie sont actuellement les seuls en
France qui continuent de brassé dans
l'enceinte d'une abbaye la consommation
mondiale de bière s'élève à environ 2
milliards d'ectolitre par an soit
l'équivalent de 6500 l de bière par
seconde et contre toute attente les plus
gros producteurs ne sont pas les
Allemands mais les Chinois quant au plus
grand buveurs là encore ce ne sont pas
les Allemands ni les Belges d'ailleurs
ce sont les tchques 150 l par an et par
personne 5 fois plus que les Français
mais je vous rassure on n'a pas à avoir
honte en mai dernier le tout premier
marathon de la bière a eu lieu chez nous
à Monbrison dans la Loire plus de 3000
personnes y ont participé en guise de
ravitaillement de l'eau et je vous donne
en 1 de la bière qui franchement n'est
pas du tout conseillé pour étancher
notre soif quand on est en plein effort
dans ce cas mieux vaut privilégier la
bière sans alcool enfin sans alcool en
réalité ces boissons en contiennent mais
un taux infime qui se situe autour de 04
% contre 4 à 6 en moyenne pour les
bières classiques cette quantité n'est
pas suffisante pour avoir des effets
néfastes sur l'organisme la composition
de la bière sans alcool ainsi que son
processus de fabrication sont les mêmes
que ceux d'une bière classique et une
étape est rajouté pour enlever l'alcool
présent dans la boisson bon allez à
cette théorie on passe à la pratique
elle va pas se faire toute seule cette
bière épicrieuse j'ai rendez-vous avec
Flor amias brasseur de
soneta
je suis à Paris dans le quartier de
Ménil montant tout près du Père Lachaise
et je me dirige vers un pub qui sert de
la bière maison entièrement fabriqué sur
place bon c'est un peu tôt on vient ici
non seulement pour déguster la bière
mais pour voir car tout se passe sous
les yeux des
clients
bonjour Merci de
maccueillir magnifique endroit cet
espace complètement ouvert où l'on
déguste la bière et où on la brasse en
même temps et j'adore cette déco enfin
je parle de déco c'est surtout du
matériel pour brasser la bière ouais
c'est tous des outils de travail servent
à brasser nos cuve pour le brassage
après on a des fermenteurs dans le fond
que tu verras tout à l'heure et au
plafond on cuve de service pour servir
la bière directement à la pression vous
produisez quel volume de bière ici on
fait des brassins de 500 l donc un
brassin c'est ça h HM c'est une
fabrication et on fait un à deux
brassins par semaine ça nous fait grosso
modo 35 ml par an bon je voudrais pas te
mettre la pression mais on a quand même
une une bière à brasser c'est parti je
te suis alors premier ingrédient pour
faire de la bière l'orge qui est à mes
pieds alors ce ne sont pas des grains
exactement comme ceux queon prélève sur
un épis ces grains ont déjà été un peu
transformés effectivement c'est du Malte
d'orge donc c'est de l'orge qui a été
trempé puis on a fait germer l'orge et
il a été séché donc ça a réveillé la
graine ça permet de libérer le sucre
qu'il y a à l'intérieur et ça va lui
donner de de la saveur et de la couleur
avec le séchage alors juste à côté il y
a d'autres grains c'est de l'orge je
suppose mais c'est pas de la même
couleur c'est toujours du Malte d'orge
en fait tout simplement il est plus
séché donc il va commencer à caraméliser
ça va donner encore plus d'arôme encore
plus de goût pour une bière embrée on va
utiliser des malles caramélisées et si
on veut faire une bière noire on utilise
par exemple du malt noir en petite
quantité mais aujourd'hui je te propose
qu'on fasse une bière plus légère
rafraîchissante sans malt noir on va
faire une bière de style gozeux une
bière de type allemand de leipsich et on
va mélanger du malt d'orge le blond avec
du blé pour donner un côté plutôt
blanche et donc ça c'est le blé mais
c'est pas du tout la même tête he lui il
est en flocon il a pas été malté ok bon
ben on y va qu'est-ce qu'on fait tout ça
maintenant et ben le Malte d il faut le
concasser donc on va aller à la machine
qui est là le moulin à malt pour le
faire très bien l'idée c'est qu'on va
concasser le malt en une farine
grossière en gardant les petites
enveloppes intactes pour nous aider à la
filtration du malt que tu verras après
je te laisse l'honneur vas-y très bien
oui on peut appeler ça un
honneur et là je verse directement
dedans alors tu verses tout vas-y ok
poser le sac pardessus
ouais c'est bon pour toi on est prêt
ah oui ça fait du bruit quand
même et voilà
ouf alors effectivement bon ça se voit
déjà à l'œil mais mais au toucher euh
c'est pas de la farine on voit que c'est
concassé que c'est grossier même si il y
a quand même un peu de farine au milieu
alors ça je te propose qu'on le prenne
on l'emène là-bas le mettre dans la cuve
d'empâage avec le blé on va le mélanger
ok c'est
parti ah il y a déjà de l'eau quel
volume 400 L et donc on va verser le
malt concassé dans cette eau c'est parti
à to l'honneur comment s'appelle cette
étape c'est l'empâage on va mélanger les
céréales pendant une heure environ 67
deg et toi pendant ce tempsl tu fais
rien moi je vais remuer je remuer avec
un Fourquet tu vas brasser en fait je
vais brasser donc le fourquet c'est un
peu comme une une fourche avec lequel on
on remue le grain pour pasqu de gremau
je peux essayer pour voir juste ce que
ça donne sauf si si là on est un moment
un moment délicat vas-y
ok ah il faut avoir de bons bras essaie
d'attaquer les les paquets de grumeau
ouais quand j'étais petit on m'app comme
ça j' grumau on ajoute le blé allez on y
va vais là
vas-y on va mettre combien de Malte
concassé là on est parti sur 50 kg de
malt et 50 kg de blé
ok c'est sportifin ça m'apprendra d'être
curieux on échange allez on échange là
on veut faire un jus de céréal bien
extraire le sucre et l'amidon qui se
trouve dans la céréale l'amidon qui est
aussi un sucre parce que c'est la
fermentation donc de ces sucres qui va
produire l'alcool que l'on trouve à
l'intérieur de la bière et à ce stade et
bien ces sucres forment des molécules
longues trop longue pour pouvoir être
transformé en alcool par les levures
qu'on ajoutera un peu plus tard donc il
faut réduire ces molécules et on va
confier ce travail à des enzymes
d'autres molécules qui sont
naturellement présentes sur le malâ ce
sont elles qui vont tenir les ciseaux et
pour qu'elle travail il leur faut un peu
de chal c'est pour cette raison qu'on a
fait chauffer lour on est à quelle
température là là on est à 67° et on va
laisser comme ça pendant une heure ok je
remets le couvercle c'est parti allez au
boulot les
[Musique]
enzymes c'est un truc de glandeur le
brassage j'a pas dû jouer
ça et voilà ça fait une heure l'empâage
est terminé je peux goûter alors on peut
goûter si tu veux
[Musique]
franchement ça pas goût de bière c'est
normal la fermentation a pas commencé et
il manque un ingrédient essentiel le
oublon le
houblon et une fois séché ça ressemble à
ça c'est en quelque sorte l'épice du
brasseur en Alsace où il est beaucoup
cultivé on le surnomme l'or ver c'est
cette plante qui apporte des arômes et
de l'amertume à la bière comme pour la
vigne il existe de très nombreuses
variétés de houblon en fonction des
terroirs avec des centaines d'arômes
différents et donc autant de saveur de
bière possible l'p par exemple l'India
pale une bière d'origine anglaise qui a
été remise au bout du jour il y a peu
contient en moyenne deux fois plus de
houblon que les autres bières c'est ce
qui lui donne ce goût très prononcé mais
ce n'est pas tout cette plante a
d'autres avantages elle permet de mieux
conserver la bière grâce à ses
propriétés antiseptiques c'est aussi un
excellent diurétique vous m'avez compris
il favorise l'élimination de l'eau par
l' c'est pour cette raison qu'on a
souvent envie de faire pipi quand on
boit de la bierre bon c'est pas tout moi
j'ai une envie pressante de voir à quoi
ressemble cette bière
épicurieuse donc ça c'est notre oublon
c'est du houblon peu lait qu'on utilise
je peux toucher bien sûr puis
sentir ah ça sent bon et là
effectivement ça sent la bière ça sent
même la ha pé donc là on va le mettre
dans la cuve d'ébullition dans le mou
pendant une heure pour infuser pour
qu'il donne son amertume ok c'est
parti et donc le mou est transféré dans
ses cuves voilà on est en train de
transférer dans les fermenteurs et c'est
là qu'on va pouvoir ajouter la levure la
levure je t'en ai mis un peu ici c'est
ça ouais on croirait un
milkshake bon c'est pas très ragouttant
c'est la même chose qu'il y a dans le
pain et sans ça on peut pas avoir
d'alcool mais une fois qu'on aura mis
cette levure ça y est on aura tous nos
ingrédients on pourra déguster notre
bière non il va falloir que la levure
travaille pendant environ 15 jours pour
qu'elle transforme le sucre en alcool et
après si on a envie on peut rajouter des
épices en l'occurrence pour la bière
qu'on fait aujourd'hui je te propose
qu'on rajoute des graines de coriandre
et des fleurs d'hibiscus qui vont
apporter de la fraîcheur et du fruité à
partir de ce moment-là on va pouvoir
déguster notre bière il faut que les
épices s'infusent et qu'il ait une phase
de garde pour que la bière s'ffine donc
faut encore attendre un mois faut être
patient alors si je fais les comptes 15
jours de fermentation pour la levure et
puis encore un mois de maturation avec
les épices ça nous fait un mois et demi
je vous rassure on va pas attendre tout
ce temps pour déguster notre bière je
crois que tu avais prévu le coup elle
est déjà à la carte on va la déguster
c'est parti je te
suis qu'est-ce que je te S et ben une
épie curieuse une épie curieuse c'est
parti avec juste ce qu'il faut de mousse
et voilà merci beaucoup en fait cette
mousse elle se forme grâce au casque
carbonique qui est dissou dans la bière
au moment où il remonte il forme des
bulles qui vont embarquer et bien des
protéines qui sont contenues dans la
bière et qui proviennent souvenez-vous
du malt et donc c'est cette matière qui
va former cette mousse un peu épaisse
qui au final est très utile sur surt
quand on boit la bière lentement comme
je le fais vous le voyez la mousse forme
une barrière qui va piéger les arômes du
coup et bien la bière reste savoureuse
tout au long de sa consommation on
trinque c'est
parti et à la
votre voilà chers épicurieuses et
épicurieux j'espère que cette vidéo vous
a plu si vous passez du côté de mî
montant venez goûter l'Épic curieuse
c'est aussi votre bière n'hésitez
à ler et à nous dire en commentaire ce
que vous avez pensé de cette vidéo sans
modération cette fois à très
[Musique]
bientôt